do you remember a while back
there is that woman who sent her husband to the store
because she wanted to make pumpkin bars
and he was talking about well
there was no pumpkin on the list
so I didn't get any pumpkin because
you know I just
how dare she not remember to put pumpkin on the list
I'll show her
I just have my own real life version of this
I am making a red wine braised beef stew
um it's gonna be kind of like a beef bouignon slash
uh pot roast
I don't really know the direction I'm going
but it's gonna be delicious
and I needed a couple ingredients
and I sent my husband to the grocery store
and I told him to get me a turnip
and he called me just now because he goes
okay so I looked
they don't have turnips
they don't have parsnips
but I did find you a rutabaga
is there any way you might want a rutabaga
and I said no
I don't want a rutabaga
it's a completely different flavor profile
and he was like
I didn't think so
but I wanted to call to check
and that my friends
is somebody who actually gives a shit to perform their task
not to mention
you went to the grocery store in like
a 30 degree weather with the baby
simply because he wanted me to have all the ingredients I needed
so they exist